Домовленість між США і Німеччиною щодо "Північного потоку-2" одні сприймають в Україні як зраду,
інші ж - як компроміс, з яким треба змиритися і працювати над наповненням цієї угоди.
Станом на тепер у ній декларується, що Німеччина запроваджуватиме санкції проти Росії,
якщо Кремль використовуватиме газ як зброю або вчинятиме подальші агресивні дії проти України.
Також Берлін обіцяє створити мільярдний спецфонд для енергомодернізації України
та сприяти продовженню угоди про транзит російського газу територією України на термін до 10 років.
Натомість США вже не заважатимуть добудові труби і не запроваджуватимуть нових санкцій.
Домовленості з Вашингтоном деякі експерти оцінюють як перемогу Меркель, німецької дипломатії і німецького бізнесу.
Водночас не всі в Німеччині раді цій угоді.
Будівництво газогону активно критикує Партія зелених, в якої є гарні шанси
увійти до нової правлячої коаліції за підсумками виборів у вересні цього року.
"Північний потік-2" буде завершено, але він був і залишається перешкодою на шляху до досягнення європейських кліматичних цілей.
У свою чергу експерт берлінського Фонду "Наука і політика" Яніс Клуґе вважає, що те,
що Вашингтон пішов на поступки Берліну, пов'язано як з приходом у Білий дім Джо Байдена,
так і зі зміною геополітичних пріоритетів Вашингтона.
Німеччина сьогодні, по суті, змогла майже повністю протиснути свою позицію у Вашингтоні.
І, звичайно, за Трампа це було б неможливо.
Ця угода є ознакою того, що американці, ймовірно, будуть менше уваги приділяти Східній Європі
та відносинам з Росією в майбутньому, що вони залишать це питання для Європейського Союзу.
Фокус США явно змістився. Тепер вони хочуть зосередитися на Китаї.
Головною умовою угоди стали можливі санкції Німеччини проти Росії в разі,
якщо Кремль застосує енергоресурси для тиску на Україну.
Але чи готовий Берлін запровадити такі санкції?
У минулому ми вже бачили, що Німеччина намагається виключити газовий сектор із санкцій проти Росії.
Насправді, в Берліні не хочуть цих санкцій.
Те ж саме було і у випадку анексії Криму, і після втручання Росії у справи Донбасу.
Німеччина хоче залишити газовий сектор за дужками і не вводити газові санкції.
Запевнення, дані Києву в рамках цієї угоди, залишаються досить нечіткими і,
по суті, не є гарантією збереження транзиту російського газу через Україну, вважають експерти.
А обіцяні інвестиції в екологічно чисту енергетику занадто малі.
В Україні люди незадоволені цією угодою, тому що вона повторює те,
що вони вже спостерігали у випадку з "Північним потоком-1".
І тепер виникають побоювання, що може статися нова ескалація.
Звичайно, Україна зацікавлена в прибутках від транзиту газу, оскільки ці доходи також ідуть на реконструкцію
існуючої системи газопроводів, яка використовується не тільки для експорту, але і для газопостачання всередині країни.
Україна та Польща все одно протидіятимуть запуску "Північного потоку-2".
Київ і Варшава вже оприлюднили спільну заяву,в якій запевнили, що працюватимуть разом зі своїми союзниками
та партнерами над протидією цій трубі, допоки не будуть розроблені рішення для подолання безпекової кризи, пов'язаної із газопроводом.
За словами опитаних DW експертів,  Києву зараз треба використовувати усі можливості на рівні ЄС,
щоб інтегрувати свій газовий ринок та ринок електроенергії у євросоюзівський і створити тим самим зону безпеки.
Те, що сьогодні прозвучало, що у разі використання газу як зброї Сполучені Штати і Німеччина будуть застосовувати санкції,
воно трішки некоректно, бо вони вже використовують газ як зброю і тому треба до цього відноситися вже як до зброї.
І говорити про необхідність роззброєння.
А роззброєння можливе тільки у разі зняття монополії "Газпрому" на постачання газу трубопроводом у Європейський Союз.
Нині Київ отримує за транзит російського газу приблизно 2 мільярди доларів на рік.
В угоді ж пропонується, зокрема створити фонд для енергомодернізації України на суму не менше 1 мільярда доларів.
Це не компенсує Україні повністю ані економічних втрат від позбавлення транзиту, ані ризиків військового конфлікту з Росією,
вважає економічний експерт Павло Кухта і додає: танки санкціями зупиняти важкувато.
Обіцянки санкцій, обіцянки тиску…
У Будапештському меморандумі були прописані безпекові обіцянки, але по факту вони не сталися,
бо щоб такі речі сталися і, коли гряне грім, хтось пішов війною і грім не грянув,
тому що росіяни не захочуть воювати із Заходом, але щоб Захід пішов на них війною,
треба розуміти, що в Заходу не буде іншого виходу.
Якщо інший вихід є, будь-які подібні обіцянки, будь-які подібні домовленості можуть в критичний момент просто не спрацювати.
У Росії ж по-різному оцінюють угоду між Берліном і Вашингтоном.
Те, що президент США Джо Байден здав назад у питанні будівництва "Північного потоку-2", легко пояснити,
зазначає партнер консалтингового агентства RusEnergy Михайло Крутіхін.
Я вважаю, що українське питання і навіть російське питання набагато менш важливі для нинішньої американської адміністрації,
ніж відновлення трансатлантичної співпраці, відновлення ролі США в НАТО,
тобто налагодження того, що зламав його попередник Трамп.
Це головна причина, чому Байден вирішив бути разом з Німеччиною, а не з кимось ще.
Якщо ж говорити про український транзит, то Київ поки і далі може розраховувати на прокачку газу через свою територію.
Думаю, що протягом п'яти років, починаючи з січня 2020 року, коли цей термін розпочався, цей транзит збережеться.
Мало того, частина транзиту все-таки збережеться, тому що деякі споживачі російського газу в Європі, наприклад,
Італія, вважатимуть за краще, як і раніше, отримувати його за старим маршрутом через Словаччину, Австрію, не зачіпаючи німецький інтерес.
А це досить великий споживач російського газу. Частина газу все-таки через Україну піде.
Багато хто чекав, що Володимир Путін намагатиметься використовувати домовленості між Меркель і Байденом у своїх пропагандистських цілях.
Однак головний редактор порталу Карнеги.ру Олександр Баунов так не вважає.
Особисто я не очікую почути від нього шапкозакидальних, роздутих тріумфаторських промов.
Побачимо голоси депутатів, кандидатів до Держдуми, які будуть подавати це як розгром України, розгром Америки, перемогу Росії.
Ну і що? В принципі, такі голоси можна було б в аналогічній ситуації почути в будь-якій країні.
Важливо подивитися на поведінку уряду, МЗС та адміністрації президента.
А те, що там скажуть по телевізору, мені здається, другорядне.
І все ж справжнім переможцем на цей момент деякі експерти називають "Газпром", Росію та особисто Путіна.
На їхню думку, в Кремлі новина про угоду США і Німеччини була сприйнята позитивно, навіть незважаючи на потенційні санкції.